le numéro un ce soir c'est moi le numéro
un je suis là veulent est numéro 1 il ya
toute la france qui me regarde là pour
faire la france
ça va vous moi ça va c'est dur en ce
moment ça va aller ça va aller on vous
l'a dit à la publicité
en france on n'a pas de pétrole mais on
a des idées ça ira ça ira ça ira je me
disais à l'industriel bien connu à son
chauffeur vous m'ont vu refuser une
augmentation
croyez-moi lucien c'est pas nous les
plus à plaindre c'est pas nous c'est pas
nous ah lalala lalala tous ces pays qui
crèvent de faim c'est pas du possible
c'est pas possible à péter de partout
les chinois les indiens les africains
sont une angoisse
shaker plus fermes atteignent j'en sais
plus rien tout ça c'est pareil
et après le journal télévisé j'ai été
saisi d'une bourde ou des poils j'ai
bien vu le mont rougis il a eu une
petite mine
oh là là des millions de gens qui
crèvent de faim je me suis je peux pas
rester immobile devant ce spectacle
il faut que je fasse quelque chose il
faut faire je suis allé au restaurant je
m'en suis foutu plein d'allant j'ai
commencé par une soupe de courge
on a eu une petite terrine à base de
têtes de veau mélangé avec du pied de
cochon très fin du gras double j'en ai
repris deux fois le toit rose et d'un
seau terme un peu d'où un peu trop doux
mais enfin les temps sont durs
voilà fait pas la peine de faire du
scandale alors qu'au bangladesh
j'ai enchaîné avec une cassolette de
queues d'écrevisses au lard ça c'était
les entrées comme viande
j'hésitais entre une oie braisé au
centre canard et un porcelet à la suède
groseille le maître d'hôtel m'a dit je
vous chipotez dans les plats comme chez
nous mais pour vous et alors le plateau
de fromages un peu de chez le cheval
peut être mince que l'iphone était un
peu fort et uni stop ça suffit
je me réserve pour le dessert qu on va
présenter la ronde et des soeurs janet
intel cafard que je me suis tapé de tous
je me suis mis jusque là j'ai dit oh
mais de tels arrêtés comme on dit
vulgairement j'ai les dents du fond qui
baigne d'ailleurs la face ça n'a pas
loupé j'ai tous vos nuits la contrariété